we're learning new details about
possible warning signs before
wednesday's
deadly mass shooting in san jose this
video shows
samuel cassidy at the valley
transportation authority during the
shooting
he fired nearly 40 rounds and appeared
to target the victims
nine men lost their lives a man now to a
man now described by investigators as
highly disgruntled
lilia luciano is in san jose lilia good
morning what else have we learned
good morning enrique an official
confirmed that cassidy had been detained
by customs and border protection in 2016
after a trip overseas they said they
found writings about terrorism
and notes detailing his hatred for his
job
our station in san francisco kpix
confirmed
that cassidy was meant to attend a
disciplinary hearing on the day of the
shooting
for allegedly making racist remarks to
his co-workers
hundreds gathered in downtown san jose
to honor those
killed in the railyard shooting how do
you want him remembered
he was the most selfless man ever he
did everything for everybody audrey
romo's family waited 12
hours wednesday to learn that her father
timothy michael romo
was one of the victims romo was a valley
transportation authority employee
for two decades his work got me through
college
got her through her fire fire training
and got my brother through
his trade school in the same trade he
was in
police say that more than 100 people
were at the vta facility when cassidy
arrived
he had three semi-automatic handguns and
32 high-capacity magazines
which are illegal in california
investigators are now serving search
warrants on his cell phone
and at his partially collapsed home they
found explosives there and believe he
set a timer or a slow burn device
to start a fire around the time of the
shooting
paul de la cruz
mejia another one of the victims 42 year
old paul mejia
is being remembered as a selfless family
man
we love you yesterday
was the saddest moment of my life his
father leonard says he lost his best
friend
and is heartbroken thinking about all
the big events
the married father of four will miss for
his uh
graduation his dad's gonna not gonna be
there
deputies arrived on the scene six
minutes after the first 9-1-1 call
they said they found him on the third
floor of one of the buildings
when they opened the door and saw him he
took his life
anthony so much pain and sand jose lilia
thank you very much